in a few reminders to begin with, I always go to our blog, that will help answer some of your
questions maybe earlier than going waiting for a Zoom call. And on our website, this little feature,
if you go to anywhere, any page on our website, this little thing right here, a little spyglass
feature gives you the ability to search for anything. We have a really good search on our site
that you can search for your question. We probably have written a blog about it or something
information about your question. If not, that's what your the Zoom calls are for. Secondly,
if you have any issues with needing religious exemptions for vaccine policies, that maybe your
work is looking for or friends or family member that needs a protocol to help detox from a vaccine
or exposure to those that are vaccinated. We ask that you go to our sister site, myhopeforlime.com
and on the blog, you'll see blog posts that detail information on this very, very stealthfully.
So my hope for lime is our sister site. Go and look.